[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je m'appelle philippe thulliez
je suis musicien et ingénieur du son est
en fait là normalement le moment qui
était prévu c'était un moment de détente
musicale avec un peu un truc un peu
festif un peu cool manque de bol ils ont
fait appel à moi déjà je n'étais pas
censé parler enfin que j'ai chopé un mec
là derrière dans des colis je vais jouer
son micro et du coup je voulais vous
parler du bruit blanc le bruit blanc ça
un truc un peu énigmatique
déjà on se demande ce que c'est le bruit
blanc ça fait un peu le bruit silencieux
le bruit transparent un truc dans le
genre là en fait le bruit blanc c'est un
truc inventé par l'homme qui est une
sorte d'accord absolue c'est toutes les
notes en même temps donc genre do ré mi
fa sol la si do mais tout
donc ça fait les d'odieuses l'airé bémol
tout ça en même temps que jusqu'à 20 de
très très graves jusqu'à l'inde aux
hypers réguler tout ça en même temps
du coup ça fait un truc qui est pas très
musical en fait pas très pas très joli
du coup justement là je voulais ce soir
devant vous vous faire une imitation du
bruit blanc à un être humain j'ai bossé
pendant six semaines donc
s
merci merci patrice c'est grâce à toi sa
victoire du coup ce truc qui paraît un
peu bizarrement ça a été inventé par
l'être humain pour calibrer des systèmes
de sons comme ce soir vous avez des
systèmes de diffusion sur les concerts
etc etc
moi je suis musicien donc du coup j'ai
plein de chez plein d'instruments jeu
alors que je vous dise un truc c'est que
je joue de la pop
donc c'est là que je joue un petit peu
de tout mais tous très mal voilà vous
voyez la musique classique les jazzman
et tous les mecs qu'ils arrivent ils
prennent le solo et tout moi c'est tout
l'inversé quoi je joue de la guitare
joue de la basse de la batterie planned
perd tout plein de trucs tout très mal
donc il faut que ce soit simple le bruit
blanc ce qui m'a intrigué au travers des
machines que je peux rencontrer dans mon
environnement quotidien à savoir les
synthés ou de genre de machine c'est que
certains synthétiseur ont justement un
générateur de bruit blanc et un jour en
recevant un d'une des machines que
j'avais commandé
voilà donc tout ça c'est mes petits
c'est multi z'enfants mais petit truc à
moi un jour la cigogne sonia massa ne
m'apporte pas bon et donc je vais ouvrir
et donc un nouveau petit bébé dans la
famille
il s'appelait le sh100 un bon ça c'est
un truc de geek on s'en fout un peu
il avait un générateur de bruit blanc et
ce générateur de bruit blanc canton de
filtres qui ont donc travaillé un peu
avec ce qu'on a
disponibilité dans la machine le truc
qui m'a frappé c'est qu'on peut assez
facilement refaire des sons de la nature
notamment le vent ou parfois l'eau et
certains éléments naturels et ça j'ai
trouvé ça assez magique en fait qu'un
truc inventé par l'homme en sachant
aujourd'hui qu'on a tendance à abîmer
énormément de choses dans notre
environnement autour de nous soit
capable d'inventer un truc qui soit
autre chose que l'affreux digital qu'on
connaît le truc hyper artificielle est
tous là en fait ça permettait de refaire
justement quelque chose d'organique
quelque chose de naturel et j'ai trouvé
ça assez assez incroyable du coup je me
suis dit finalement je fais partie de la
nature fut un animal je suis une bête
comme une autre donc je dois être
capable de pouvoir faire ce genre de son
et m'intégrer dans tout ça du coup j'ai
voulu utiliser cette machine qu'on
appelle l'ordinateur
et qui aujourd'hui permet de faire
énormément de choses mais parfois c'est
un peu de la triche pas ce qu'on peut
faire plein de trucs on peut pré
enregistrer des sons du coup j'ai voulu
utiliser cette machine mais pour
justement revenir vers quelque chose
d'un peu naturelle d'un peu organique
pour voilà pour détourner un peu les
outils qui nous sont proposées
aujourd'hui
donc du coup voilà j'ai maintenant je
vais je vais arrêter de parler je vais
rendre le micro et je vais vous faire
une petite impro musical s'est pas
vraiment de la musique un peu c'est un
peur format donc voilà soyez indulgents
ouvert d'esprit
après on dit aujourd'hui justement dans
les vibrations à quelque chose d'assez
thérapeutique c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
dans le domaine de la santé on sert des
vibrations à différentes fréquences donc
les fréquences et les notes justement du
grave à l'aigu pour soulager les gens
donc je vais essayer de faire quelque
chose qui peut éventuellement vous
soulager en tout cas il ya une option
thérapeutique sachez le ce qui est
positif
comme on dit quand on n'aime pas le goût
c'est l'effet du médicament qui compte
et pour les plus sensibles fond du
couloir 2e à gauche qui est l'étoile est
là je vous remercie je souhaite une
bonne séance
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
non
à
[Musique]
ah ah
à
[Musique]
oh
à
hahaha
ah ah
[Musique]
mon
oh
[Musique]
m
ah ah
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]